[Musique]
je suis venu vous parler ce soir dû
faire de vos enfants
les idoles des six pôles
les stars venues et dames et messieurs
est ce que vous savez que les stades
cubes et les icônes de dieu mais les
étoiles déjeuner force avec le cerveau
enfant aujourd'hui je suis venu vous
parler de marielle mon fils nous avons
nous sommes des stars des dicos que nous
admirons tout d'abord au mieux 2021 et
lise méthot que je vous demande d'être
appelée sous l'ère des harmonies
chorales nous avons angélique idiot aimé
césaire a trouvé la mort aimé césaire
dit bonjour et que ses enfants
cette boîte je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas seulement
les revenus baissaient également les
autres m'ont fait un des roms aussi les
dipôles que nous à venir alors
moi mes mots car on a bien vu les
partenaires lorsqu'ils avaient très
honnêtement que je suis prédication de
l'évangile de ces supplices et samedi
soir lorsque je préparais de messages
pour les dimanches j'ai remarqué que mon
garçon a commencé pas débité et à 4 ans
il a commencé à prêcher à la maison et
un jour il me dit papa je vais prêcher
pour toi
jeudi le dis moi si bien nous allons
nous donner l'opportunité et le dimanche
maugard ont étudié pour pêcher et je
voudrais passage un peu une partie de ce
qu'il a fait ce joueur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà une star et peinait à la surprise
de tous il comme moi même
alors j'ai pensé quoi déplaire au point
qu'il est là ça que j'arrive qu il n
écoute que sa pire qu'il ait cette
étoile mondiale que je suis après
devoirs et ses paroles lui donner
confiance à turin celle que je n'en
pense que nous allons
et voilà que josy lui plaire et dit papa
je vais faire recette
il voit une musique il pas parlé chanté
cette chanson et de la chanter mieux que
c'est fait l'achat 6 mbit/s très bien et
je voudrais bien voir plus bas des sept
et ses liens avec le monde
oh
non
à
j'ai produit avant que chaque enfant a
toutes les capacités que les irsc et le
brésil pourvu qu'on l'emploie et ceci a
amené ariel a commencé par être
développées tout ou pas c'est selon
l'humeur des passagers
il a subi le film genfit et des
tricheurs
le titre était paratechnique et mini
papa je vous l ai travaillé et vous la
verrez dans une école de karaté et la
même année il ya vu le championnat local
a reconnu et avait terminé à la maison
avec la médaille du champion je n'ai
plus besoin de booster chez moi je n'ai
plus besoin déjà richard jamais rien
et ceci a amené la guerre a commencé par
développer votre talent signé ici qu'il
me fait du mannequinat
il a commencé par faire les mains des
kinés la commande battre angers et
avrillé du bois pas je vais fait que
l'amour âge mais jouer en effectif
j'avais de jouer dans un film et j'ai
négocié avec leur mini jeu égal il a
fait ça paie les pots l'ailier anglais
qui voulait mener un film documentaire
sur les albinos est utile et plein droit
d'être heureux a bien été remis
les acteurs et appelle à tous les
enfants de tout tu deviennes la crise
ivoiro mini one d appel
solange 3d et le film était le puits du
parc est allé plus loin il m'a dit papa
- quand je vois les nouveaux métiers
ils accueilleront un show des ivoiriens
et nigériens forme basket mois ou bien
attendre à la fois du moins je me
faisais mon mieux
cela ne sert à rien à garder le public
pendant huit minutes dans les vagues
dans les filets je veux pas faire toi
même que tu pars tu y es mauvais jours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il m'a dit qu'il me fait de la
photographie je lui ai acheté un
appareil photo professionnel qui est la
principale fait des photos et la
majorité défend beaucoup de moi je pose
substitut réseaux sociaux célèbre tout
fait pas arrière et ses plumes et un des
meilleurs sujets il terme
c'est sa mère et moi et sa petite soeur
je partage avec vous big fuel
que vient faire la fête à boire et à sa
maman
une photo qui nous demandent si les u17
n'est paraît-il à laquelle est venue me
voir après avoir subi une vidéo d'une
chanteuse béninoise
celle ci mais il n'y pas pas je vais
chanter une chanson de festive et mais
je fais moi même joué le diamant et
chanter la chanson je veux que tu
m'achètes fiable car je suis le premier
animateur
je veux que tu m'achètes une jeanne et à
la fin de l'année comme il a l'habitude
de le faire
il était alors je suivais sociale nous
avons acheté ou bien tu veux qu'on veut
gagner ensemble avec moi une petite
partie de ce qui arrive pour effet avec
soutien
avant guingamp
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regardez notre spécial non pas dans la
foulée vous il a des défauts mais rien
et femmes et sa chance c'est qu'il a des
parents qui ont préféré vous ne prêtez
pas et s'occuper de lui pour lui comme
rfi et ceux ci contient les parents de
louis-joseph est qu'ils appellent à
beignon amboise delicti aucune enfin les
carrés il suffit seulement de lui donner
ici d'abattage aussi pour lui et de lui
voler du souhait
ceci a fait perdre hier un jeu un enfant
mais qui voit pas dans la bd
aujourd'hui il y en a dix ans et il
n'applique pas tenir plus jeunes motivés
qui se tient aujourd'hui la préhistoire
pour encourager les chantres succès ce
qui a mené à une agence de production
audiovisuelle après le one shot qui est
venu voir bien besoin d'aidé travaille
sur un concept que l'ugtt et myla est
bouclée
à l'époque c'est à dire les procédés
revenir derrière aujourd'hui mais
raconte des histoires il fait des vidéos
pour motiver les gens consultés je vous
faire voir
le secret a invité les indiens du maire
my name is aryenne un homme namias aux
coptes wittstock abbas et m elle m'a
poussé et pink you fat 10 opportunity
qui veut être une mine pas cette
contrainte à ses caisses figure dans la
nuit et jour date outlet utah culture
des corps et du cash
we have in africa ayant de ce peuple
chinois de planet in the witcher
continue living conditions indoor espada
scott en libye back in by éducation wima
smic soit un ryokan boys and girls mais
elle me met un accent tout éducation
mesdames et messieurs
chaque enfant a du potentiel pour
devenir historique mais il pourrait
simplement de la découvrit pourtant des
choses qui servent bien sûr vous surtout
ne pas dire tous les indices à mieux
nous devons décourager et leurs grades
et les oies poules habits
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]